a local family is pleading for the
public's help as they search for a
missing teenager 16-year-old chase
williamson was last seen on friday and
his mother says she's looking for any
information that could help bring him
home jeremy j ford is live in the
newsroom tonight with the latest details
jeremy
well chase williamson's parents say they
are desperately searching for their son
tonight they're asking for your help
we just need information we need we need
those individuals that have the
information to get in contact with
angels vegas or the police
a plea from a loving mother whose
teenage son hasn't returned home since
he left for work friday afternoon on his
red bicycle he got off at nine
supposedly it was thunderstorms that
night so i went up to pick him up
went inside the guy said that he had
left a while ago on saturday chase's
bike was found here in this dumpster
behind albertson's just five miles away
from his job at mr jim's pizza we
haven't retrieved the bike yet we're
going to pick that up today
we were mainly focused on getting out
the report to the police
putting this all over social media and
trying to talk to any of his friends
online that we could
and finding out if anybody had seen him
so far the williamson family has been
following up on the few leads they have
they say chase's cell phone has been off
since he left work fellow employees say
he's been a no call and no show at work
the last two days
well chase williamson is about 5 foot 10
inches and weighs around
155 pounds he has short brown hair blue
eyes and braces and chase was last seen
wearing his work uniform which includes
blue jeans a pink shirt and that said mr
jim's
uniform he might have also been wearing
a black visor well anyone with
information on chase's whereabouts is
asked to notify metro police at the
number on your screen and that's 702 828
314
from the newsroom jeremy j ford live
local now